this is seem when you're watching JK
news in too much paradise news submitted
by missing phone charges a man who says
he fled an Austrian prison over a decade
ago has turned himself in Wow why you
fled you did a great job the world was
too cruel hmm probably I don't know I
don't know this article but he probably
was very disillusioned with the world I
bet you the Austrian prison is better
than most areas in the world so he's
like hot rap to go back to [ __ ] bring
me all hot soft fat soft bed free
bratwurst so this man is 64 years old
he spent the last ten and a half years
in a very popular vacation island in the
Spanish Canary Islands what is that mean
is it you sure I literally just said the
Spanish Canary I know but there's also
like the British whatever Islands and
they're in like the Caribbean you know I
mean it's just because it has British
Virgin Islands yeah yeah there just
doesn't mean that there next to it just
means we got colonized by your [ __ ]
face yeah he doesn't Rose did your eyes
will see when she says or like the
America like we were gonna visit the
canary on its butt cause I like like the
American bombing it is not many ways yes
we're not going to the Canary Islands
it's in our face is it what is it it's
not the coast of Morocco well done hold
on hold on I'm just seeing the truth
it's supposed to say anybody thank you
Joe but but you know what I knew what
Bart was talking about the whole point
because there's us Puerto Rico yeah
there's like the French Polynesian
islands are not cold what how good does
that feel dude feels really good
Oscar okay like French Polynesia is not
anywhere near friends yes it is why
didn't have so many Samoans in Paris
buzzer uh-huh
that's just so cool I know it okay what
are you searching now know the name or
the name of the island tracklist no
because it says Spain under it it's the
part of Spain look Tenerife it's this
beam right there because it's a
territory of Spain yeah there's no
technicality in the location Bart was
right on this one right right there boom
already bound like that didn't you
humbled yourself okay I'm getting soft
in my old age pushing a child out that
[ __ ] dude just [ __ ] the week is your
book don't think about my party no you
thought about my [ __ ]
please stop it funny did you matter to
be lost better to be wrong in my sweat
now wrong and learning that's weird
then try to be right in Bronk what did
you just say it's better to be wrong and
learning then try to be right when
you're wrong true also now all the
hundreds of thousands of people are now
thinking about Canary Islands you did oh
my god I need these tissues really does
it look like Josephine's Thomas Moore
hey that's all [ __ ] it came out of my
[ __ ]
just like that tissue all torn up yeah
but dry enough anyways so this man said
they had been there for the last ten and
a half years and he wanted to return
home because Tenerife is not as nice as
they used to be and he had lived there
long enough I mean there's a lot of
other countries the nerve of this guy so
many other places that you could
carrying two suitcases he went to the
police at the Salzburg railway station
and told them that he was a fugitive
prisoner and he had just arrived from
Munich Airport and so they verified that
he was a
prisoner and they took him back to
prison how did he escape so he was just
done with his vacation and what was he
in for originally like an honesty call I
have so many questions as well and all
the information I gave you he would come
and they're like that's cool yeah me too
just go back he's like I want to go to
jail ultimate punishment now you can't
you're not welcome here anymore yeah we
go back when I'm 80 or something I would
never go back we're still young I think
if I was the owner of the prison cuz I
guess that's how prisons work ah and
then he wanted to come back and be like
nah you want this no you can't come back
but what if you miss your friends that's
why because she wants it that's such a
girl thing to do I'm like man I wish I
miss one I Larry he was so good at poker
and then you just at the vacation spot
and you're like man I'd rather go back
cuz it's not everyone here is lame but
it's who you were a more interesting
people over there that's what my dad did
my dad missed his elementary school
friends we went back to China to find
them in half a more dead wait when did
he go back like last year like two years
ago oh yeah a lot more just dead oh that
was a very expensive trip yeah China
yeah scape China and then he went back
and you he knocked on their doors as if
they're gonna live in the same house in
shape he has numbers to a couple of
friends
oh so don't talk to other friend in
Delhi okay let's get everybody together
let's see what's happening could you
just tell them hey don't even come half
of them are gone no because they don't
some people are like in from different
cities move to other cities it's a glass
half empty half full you all of your
friends are also half alive yeah that's
cool they could all you Turtle together
turn on a turtle and crickey like y'all
let's get the boys back we need some
ready or sliders in our life again
turtle shells and Darla's okay I want to
see that day like they're actually
eating Turtles I think you might because
they're so slow they're gonna turn his
story when he went to China and he had
her oh yeah with my dad when I was in
Middle School
so first went to Hong Kong and then we
went to where my other relatives lived
and the since it was like a big like
family reunion they're like okay let's
cook up the Barmes dishes it's all I was
excited to I was all who are we gonna
eat that I'd never get a chance to eat
and the first thing that came out and
great yeah it was a plate of these likes
softshell turtles like a stack of like
four and I'm like what da [ __ ] and it
smelled like [ __ ] and they were eating
it like it was KFC would you eat it now
I'll try it but what's McDonald's oh you
eat all kinds of [ __ ] now [ __ ] now try
it but it does this ship was I would I
would maybe eat a slice of something
that would that if you told me it was
turtle but I would not if you were if I
was staring in the face of one just like
that's I can't eat chicken feet it's
like the whole like the bones Bob I just
think of it as Dragon Claw see a turtle
that that's difficult that's weird
love Kenny no gotta go feed you know
what's better than chicken feet duck
[Laughter]
give me a challenge that I don't [ __ ]
good why do I have to make a choice he
said bass eat some duck sighs two
different courses of the same meal I
used to be anti chicken feed to never
get that straight I always try to
explore but I just never knew that part
existed answering your ask question
I don't know that part was so
sensational I didn't know but everything
you're saying could be talking about
Chicopee - I like to spit out the little
bits after just never expected a chicken
feed yeah cuz like my favorite part of
the chicken is the skin you know what
chicken ass is actually you know people
about they're like you know wouldn't you
know that fried chicken thing that
you're getting the Chinese this but when
they bring the whole chicken up and the
head is like this and [ __ ] and they
leave the ass I didn't know but the ass
was up was a part that was like juicy
you talking about the booty oh no cuz I
saw butthole you saw a hole maybe I'm
wrong when you're right take a right
turn into the left leg yeah but the tail
the chicken tail and the two two oysters
are my favorite part of the chicken so
when you have the bottom of a chicken
and you turn it around there's these two
things called oysters that are the
breastplate thing uh yeah on the on the
stomach area
so I'm stomach area so you you'll pop it
out and it's literally like this
circular little piece of meat oh those
two things and the chicken tell about
you three favorite parts cartilage a
cute Ari it's my favorite drumsticks and
ass baby yeah but I used to be scared of
chicken feet I would look at dancing I'm
like you [ __ ] me Andrew you know how
I did it I mashed it up when he wasn't
looking I threw it on his plate and then
he was like what's this and he ate it
you know cuz it taste is fine I don't
taste her but you'll like chicken skin
it's chicken skin just that's never did
a bone but I like to eat it right out I
don't know I like it now I like it I eat
a lot of [ __ ] now before I didn't a lot
of ass that I know I know
means up the whole shape of it cuz I was
able to eat like live squid but it was
trapped up like if it was a whole last
thing I think I could do it oh it's just
a whole shape free cuz you could see it
like the [ __ ] talons it's too much
well what if you break it up well that's
what I think I have eaten it when it's
chopped up have you had [ __ ] duck
fingers though no no web the web's or
web feet yeah you could eat yes that's
talk about Asian or Chinese people
specifically they eat everything what do
they do they cut though and web and fry
it into it Joe it's literally the web
but they chop it into like three pieces
yeah hey that's Sam whoo so like they
just busted it out for like appetizers
and in the I was just like what it means
like it's on the house and I'm I I tried
it I was like okay I think get used to
this but what I really liked it is when
we did the skit and do you message it as
a prank the practical joke and you're
like bro this is the best is so good you
sick [ __ ] it was garbage now when I when
I really got into it is remember the
skit that we did at Tommy's house that's
all yeah we specifically did one where
we had duck and we're playing drums with
it
yes and then we put Doug feet inside of
the pie
I forgot what reason but his mom
insisted that she would cook the duck
feet like and I was like okay we're just
gonna use it for prop so she made it
legit she stuck it on there and I got
hungry so I tried one and it was [ __ ]
amazing and I was like okay I'm hooked I
love duck feet try when you're when
you're afraid of eating food try it when
you're extremely hungry and then you'll
start liking it that's a good point yeah
that's true - it was quacking
[Music]